when Jordan had me on his show he did
this pay World section that they do at
the end and he was asking me about my
background whatever and I talked we
talked about when I was homeless in the
secret
oh uh we talked about when I was
sleeping in the park and and I told the
story about um I used to smoke back
then and uh I was just I had nothing to
do all day cuz that's what that's what
it is to be homeless and and not to have
a job at that time Etc I was just
walking around and this guy was waiting
for a bus and he lit a cigarette and I
was oh [__] hell and the bus came so
he got upset dropped the cigarette and I
remember picking that cigarette up and
in that moment it was the lowest that
I've ever felt ever and that was the
moment I decided I'd never I'd never be
there again I'm never coming back here
and he was like that's right when you
want to do things in your life it's
helpful to know the heaven that you're
going to but it's also very useful to
have a hell behind you that you're
moving away from and that's what you're
talking about this is why it's I think
that's such a great reframe because the
the alternative to going for it and
trying things and doing your best and
actually attempting to achieve the thing
you you you're meant to achieve and I
really believe in in in that sense of
Destiny in a way is not comfort and sort
of everything's all right it's [__]
terrible and that that a great reframe
and I love that yeah you know Dana White
said uh I [__] love that guy I know
we're both we're both big we're both big
fans of him Dana we're coming for you
um he had this really great reel that
someone repurposed that said um I I
think he's got Sons uh he has yeah uh I
I tell my sons it's all out there for
the taking right now if you have a gram
of talent and an ounce of hard work
you'll run these [__] over and it's
like it's true like there is that the
bar has never been set lower and I
understand you know if you wallow in
Reddit and the dark recesses of Twitter
that you can believe that you are a
genetic dead end as a man and there is
nothing that you can do or as a woman
that the culture is you're kind of at
the mercy of the culture in a way and
you maybe feel like you missed a Time Of
Glory or that was more appropriate for
you maybe it was the the 1950s or maybe
it was the [__] Middle Ages I don't
know right you feel wistful for a life
that you never got to
lead but the the truthful fact is I
don't think there's ever been a time
where there's been more
opportunity and a lower degree of
competition AG that we've just said the
average American that's the average
American right yeah obese less than 1K
in the bank and divorced right like just
it's so low and I I understand that it
can seem like you're talking from an
ivory Tower or well done you had this
sorted but I didn't have it sorted I
didn't have it sorted for a very long
time n you know I I I had days where
getting one foot out of my bed onto the
floor was a t T so great that I couldn't
do it right that I just couldn't bear to
open the curtains I couldn't bear to
speak to anybody and ostensibly outside
I had the entire life sorted okay so
what does that tell you tells you that
material conditions don't actually
always determine your internal state so
don't presume that the things that
you're chasing for are actually going to
fix whatever your internal problem is
and also don't use your external State
as an excuse for the way that your
internal feelings are that's not to say
that you can't get to a state of
destitution where it's pretty much
impossible to be happy yeah
but